And over about it, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's getting to we're going to be talking on this video of juicine and
blood-dead basics
There's a lot of controversy. Should I be juicine? Should I be blood-dead?
Should I even be doing this at all? Well in our basic
pre-
knowing what your genetics are diet? I'm not to pose to you not do it either juicine or blood-dead right now
We'll explain a little bit why
But there's some things that you'll want to know in this so as we go through this
I hope this will explain it. So we're juicine or bloodied. What should we do? The debate continues. Well
There's benefits of both. Juicers will extract the juice from the vegetables that they'll even dry pulp as a waste
Blending vegetables keeps the pulp. Now the negative of
Blending vegetables with keeping the pulp it makes it much more bitter
If you've ever drink juice from a juicer, it's pretty tasty
Because the pulp is gone. The fiber is gone. That's what makes the juice taste more bitter and
You mainly have sugar left. Well, that can be a negative
If you're going to do either of these using carrots, celery, apple and beetroot as a base if you're on a low-protein diet
But the problem is if you're doing this as you don't know which diet you should be on yet
Then you have to be more careful use greens and non-root vegetables if you're on a keto-like diet
If you don't know we haven't got your genetics back yet and you don't know what you should be on
You're probably safer using the greens and non-root vegetable a ketogenic-like diet that you are
using a lot of carrots, celery and apple and you're probably much safer
Blending versus juicing and I'll explain why so I typically tell people that they should blend
Versus juice until we get your genetics back because if you're
Cancer based upon your genetics is
Probably fed through the pathway of glycolysis. We have to eliminate
All you know all carbs which would really strictly reduce your carbs
You're going to be going on a ketogenic-like diet. Well your juicing carrots, celery, apple and beets, holy cats
You're getting a lot of glucose
Feeding right down glycolysis and you're going to build up a lot of elastic acid
Which could be a fuel source of the cancer
Now a Gershund type juicing program can be really good for some people
That's the argument. Well, so and so I did a Gershund program of juicing and they healed their cancer. Well, that's great
They probably did not have defects
PDH defects HIF defects a different genetic defects that pointed towards the cancer feeding off of lactic acid
Other people did juicing and they did poorly because they should have been on a ketogenic diet
That's why we got to look at your genes
But here's the benefits of juicing if your goal is to consume large quantities of juice like on a Gershund diet where you're juicing
13 glasses 12 glasses of juice a day you have to juice
There's simply it's impossible for you to drink 12 glasses of blended vegetables in a day you'd explode
So that's what you have to do if you're trying to juice
So understand why I'm going to person juice are blended all the reason is is that you're pre-digesting the food
so
You are doing the work of there's no way that you could chew it up that well
So you're really taking a lot of pressure off of your gut
So there's benefits of getting this raw food
juice or blended is a raw food because it's not being cooked
But the problem with raw food is it's difficult to digest so if you're pre-digesting it by juicing it
Or blending it it's saving that pressure on your
Stubbic and your peycreatic enzymes. So it's going into the intestines
Pre-digested and it's going to be more readily absorbed and you're going to get much greater
nutritional value from your food
So there's I am huge on juicing and blending. It's very beneficial
But we have to know what your genetics are before we get too deep into it
There's negatives of juicing. We already spoke of that
Juicing expels the pulp. Well, that's what makes it taste good because you don't don't have that pulp
Well, it's easier to drink a lot of juice
Yeah, but the problem is you're going to be consuming a whole lot of glucose
With that juice because if vegetables have glucose to you
Every gram of sugar offsets is offset by a gram of fiber
So if you're taking it on the fiber out you just have all those grams of glucose
So you're really getting a high
gram of glucose per day and that's not always good. Okay
The benefits of blending well the benefits of blending are I prefer it because that fiber is very beneficial
for your digestion
if it's a more
Difficult to digest fiber it becomes a prebiotic
So if you watch the gut check video we'd want more prebiotics because that's what helps your body your gut
Make butarate in order to heal itself in order to hold a microbiota your flora
So that your body could heal from the inside out. I typically suggest a nutra bullet or a Vitamix or
We used to have a nutra bullet. We had a Vitamix for years who know we have one of those did jet blenders ourselves
And bloody the other thing about juicing versus blending people buy a juicer with these great intentions
I'm going to start juicing in my life is going to be changed in about two weeks into it
They want to hit it with the baseball bat because it's a pain in the tail to clean
If you're just really really good at that kind of stuff and you might say that
I'm a juicing for five years every day. Well, that's great
I personally don't even have time to juicing and even think about that
So blending is very easy. You just rinse the blades off and you throw the cup into the
dishwasher or rinse it out and it makes it really easy to clean up
So you also have to be a little more of a realist too
Remember one of my premises of our entire program is that if you're spending your entire life
Um all the hours of your day trying to be healthy that why are you trying to be healthy for if that's all you have time for is trying to be healthy
So we want to make sure that we're not making an idol out of trying to be healthy and wasting all our time and doing so
The benefit of blending fits into that because it's really easy and it's really quick
So I'm
Fallen to the the realm that blending is better especially when we don't know if you're
Your genetics point to the possibility of
your cancer being fed through glycolysis and and
And lactic acid and certainly if you juiced it would just be a fuel line for the cancer
So before we know that you're much better blending what do we do though even though that you could be much better blending too
So you're safe for probably starting blending for sure
I hope that covers it or that clears it up for you and there are some benefits to these videos
Uh, and that you're blessed by him. All right. Bye-bye